the wait is over jennifer lopez and ben
affleck are instagram official
on saturday the rekindle romance was
confirmed with this pda-packed pick
we need to control that i don't know how
that happened to celebrate her birthday
lopez shared this group of swimsuit
shots from a yacht and sandra pay
if he kept on swiping waiting at the end
was the passionate kiss with her man
52 lopez captioned the picks quote
52 and what it do while they've been
frequently spotted together
this marks the first time the couple has
posted about each other on their social
media
we're gonna give it away but it has a
very good ending the pick comes just
days after they were seen celebrating
another b
day this time it was lopez's close
friend leah remini
it was one of those instant chemistry
things right where you just feel like
i love this person in the black and
white photo remini shared to instagram
aflac is seen wrapping his arm around
the two besties
and it's been almost a week since hoda
kotb made a play for some benefit
details
but truth be told i had to ask
jennifer about benefer benefer
during her appearance on the today show
lopez shied away from any discussion
about the relationship
are we happier the song is out
wait it's me you're talking to you know
that i know you can call me you have my
number meanwhile ben and jen have been
spotted house hunting in los angeles
confirming some new details about that
rapidly advancing romance
a source told et that lopez and
affleck's friends quote
wouldn't be surprised if they moved in
together and ultimately ended up
together
the source added quote they're spending
all of their free time together and
making each other a priority
jlo falls hard and has certainly done
the same with ben again this time around
i think we have chemistry as actors from
the first moment we started working
aflac and lopez began dating in 2002
quickly followed by the couple
announcing their engagement we're trying
to
get some can you see if we can get in
the papers i'm trying to get
could i could i but in 2003 the wedding
was called off just days before
their planned ceremony in september and
they officially called off the
engagement in january 2004
but remained on friendly terms following
the split it was my first
kind of heartbreak lopez opened up about
their breakup to e.t
in 2014. yeah i mean i had like a puppy
love heartbreak when i was like 12.
you know what i mean but no i don't
really count that one it was my first
like adult heartbreak
was it because it was so public and we
wanted to know every single
thing about your relationship well that
didn't help
sorry that didn't help but um
no it was just it was just one of those
things you know i was an adult we were
about to get married
it didn't work out and it was just a bad
[Music]
heartbreak